[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation
d'association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Florence Camoin
directrice du Théâtre Coluche à Plaisir
bonjour bonjour à votre salle de
spectacle est située à plaisir les
Yvelines et 50 ans en Yvelines
renferment une force culturelle évidente
sur le territoire est-ce que vous
estimez justement que votre salle de
spectacle les forces de proposition en
termes de programmation culturelle oui
nous accueillons beaucoup de création de
résidence beaucoup aussi en jeunes
publics oui c'est un peu l'idée c'est
quand même d'être un lieu de création
tout autant que de diffusion des
spectacles parce que c'est un des
meilleurs moyens pour que le public
rencontre les artistes autrement une
programmation ça ne se fait pas du jour
au lendemain alors comment justement se
font les choix de spectacle au sein de
votre programme
je vois 150 à 200 spectacles par an donc
je vais quasiment tous les soirs au
théâtre jusqu'à ce que je trouve le coup
de coeur je vais rencontrer des artistes
j’assiste à des lectures je j'essaye
d'être force de proposition sur des
projets de création donc c'est tout un
travail sur le long terme de longue
haleine donc c'est surtout des coups de
coeur finalement que que vous programmez
c'est j'ai envie de partager quelque
chose avec les spectateurs j'ai envie
que les artistes et le public se
rencontrent autour de projets que j'ai
adoré c'est une question de partage vous
attaquer la deuxième partie de la saison
2022 2023 on va justement parler un de
cette programmation pour les mois de
février et mars prochain alors le 11
février vous proposez un voyage au
milieu des pirates avec le spectacle
pirate le destin d'Evan Kingsley c'est
une comédie musicale à découvrir en
famille on va écouter un extrait du
spectacle et on poursuit juste après
[Musique]
tout d'abord mes bons camarades mille sa
mort nous sommes des pirates tout ça
l'abordage sous le vent le Pavillon Noir
nous sommes des pirates
[Musique]
au bout d'un doigts du vent abordable au
bâtiment maintenant
chantons la vie fier de force ci-dessus
tout était pour toi dans ta gueule alors
pirate le destin devine Kingsley c'est
donc le 11 février au Théâtre Coluche
pouvez-vous nous en dire un peu plus
justement sur cette comédie musicale un
gros coup de coeur c'est énorme décor
chanson magnifique décorates
chorégraphie incroyable c'est des
costumes aussi somptueux on est plongé
vraiment dans Pirates des Caraïbes quoi
mais sur scène et ce spectacle a été
soutenu à l'origine par Christophe
Lambert qui en avait assez de voir des
comédies musicales un peu neuneus et pas
abouti là il y a eu un travail
extraordinaire quoi ces dignes de
Mogador c'est du vraiment du du gros
spectacle plaisir pour le plaisir à
plaisir et franchement venez avec les
enfants à partir s'étend venait avec les
grands-parents parce que c'est pour
toute la famille et ça fait trop du bien
quoi de ce genre de spectacle et alors
le 16 février c'est Madame pilinsky le
secret de Chopin qu'est ce qui attend le
public et bien ils vont voir Éric
Emmanuel Schmitt se faire torturer par
une vieille professeur de piano
polonaise très
exigeante qui ne rigole pas du tout avec
Chopin et là il va réapprendre le piano
complètement et en plus il y a ce
pianiste monsieur stavi qui est un
immense pianiste qui joue du Chopin ça
vous arrache les tripes franchement à ne
pas manquer le 10 mars c'est une pièce
d'Oscar Wilde qui sera à découvrir avec
l'importance d'être constant la pièce a
été adaptée par Pierre Arcan pouvez-vous
nous en dire un petit peu plus sur ce
sur ce spectacle et sur cette adaptation
alors mais si
Oscar Wilde très bien vu très bien
compris dans son texte dans son humour à
l'anglaise
est charmante avec une Évelyne d'huile
qui est fantastique en maman protectrice
complètement écervelée une distribution
prodigieuse décor costume c'est un grand
moment de bonheur de partager cette
langue qui est tellement subtile très
subtil et très drôle sur cette histoire
de jeune homme qui s'est invente un
double en fait c'est moche c'est pour
avoir une petite copine à la campagne et
une autre à Paris quoi donc il invente
qu'il allait voir son son double pour
disparaître et rencontrer l'une ou
l'autre suivant ses besoins et qui
essaye d'initier un de ses amis à cette
technique
alors là on l'a vu il y a une petite une
petite absence de spectacle mais c'est
lié au vacances entre le 16 février le
10 mars sinon à part ça on voit que
pratiquement toutes les semaines il y a
au moins un spectacle c'est aussi une
volonté de proposer une nouveauté chaque
semaine un nouveau spectacle chaque
semaine oui une formation c'est tout un
ensemble de spectacles qui sont tous
très différents les uns des autres qui
sont uniques qui sont originaux drôles
novateurs ou tendre mais qui ont chacun
quelque chose de différent à porter moi
mon ambition évidemment c'est que les
spectateurs reviennent toutes les
semaines et qui voient l'ensemble de la
programmation pour en saisir justement
toute la diversité et qu'ils aient le
sentiment à chaque fois de nouveautés
quoi de que ça soit pas du formatage
comme quelquefois sur certaines chaînes
c'est pas du formatage c'est différent
c'est original à chaque fois et c'est
différentes formes de bonheur au théâtre
alors pour donner une petite idée de du
spectacle l'importance d'être constant
on va écouter un extrait et on poursuit
juste après vous ne parlez pas
sérieusement quand vous disiez que vous
ne voyez pas même si je ne m'appelle pas
constant mais vous elle est
Constantine
le plus conscient que j'ai jamais
rencontré
vivement d'acquérir une famille au plus
vite pour produire au moins un parent
mal ou femelle avant la fin de la téton
catégoriquement de données me
consentement mais pour quelle raison
[Musique]
je
on peut demander plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'importance d'être constant donc c'est
le 10 mars au Théâtre Coluche et le 18
mars c'est le spectacle La Traviata qui
s'invite au sein de votre théâtre que
raconte la pièce et pourquoi l'avoir
programmée mais c'est le tube de de
verti La Traviata c'est la dame aux
camélia
c'est comme Carmen quoi si les deux
opéras les plus vues dans le monde et là
c'est une nouvelle mise en scène
l'année dernière nous avions accueilli
un Mozart avec opéra nomade les Noces de
Figaro les gens avaient adoré de voir de
l'Opéra dans un théâtre déjà ça faisait
longtemps qu'il y en avait pas eu au
théâtre Coluche parce qu'on a pas de
fausses d'orchestre mais finalement on a
réussi à trouver une solution c'est la
musique en live c'est vraiment c'est en
partenariat avec l'atelier lyrique de
Clermont-Ferrand donc avec une
distribution européenne voire
internationale et voilà c'est comment
comment rentrer dans dans la musique de
Verdi avec les chanteurs l'orchestre ça
fait du bien d'être immergé dans les
instruments et les champs le 24 mars
c'est une pièce mise en scène par
Eric pardon Bouvron ça s'appelle
Laurence d'Arabie dites nous un petit
peu plus justement sur ce spectacle
alors énorme coup de cœur j'ai suivi la
création de ce spectacle depuis
l'origine et j'ai enfin pu le découvrir
au Théâtre des Halles au Festival
d'Avignon et ce qui a voulu faire eric
Bouvron c'est ne pas reprendre le film
vous savez le célèbre film aura au
marché arrive Peter U2 c'est vraiment de
se plonger dans la vraie histoire de
Laurence d'Arabie la façon dont il a été
manipulé en fait pour entraîner derrière
lui les tribus arabes et comment
derrière ça aboutit à une forme de
trahison et comment ça ça influait sur
l'histoire aujourd'hui et la relation
avec ces pays qui est difficile quand
même d'autant plus que c'est eux qui ont
le pétrole pour la plupart donc c'est
c'est assez passionnant en plus il a mis
une chanteuse lyrique il a réussi à
reproduire toute cette ambiance on a
l'impression d'être transporté dans dans
le désert c'est vraiment une une pièce
d'aventure et c'est donc à découvrir le
24 mars au Coluche a plaisir un
spectacle qui pourrait intéresser les
personnes qui n'y comprennent pas grand
chose au dark web et à la crypto-monnaie
avec le spectacle hpns marché pirate sur
le Darknet quelles sont les objectifs de
ce spectacle moi je fais partie d'une
génération qui a la base ni comprenait
rien du tout à la crypto monnaie et du
coup j'ai pu grâce à cette création qui
qui va bientôt arriver chez nous la
première a eu lieu tout récemment
c'est vraiment essayer de comprendre ce
qu'est le Dark web ce qui est un Bitcoin
ce qu'est la crypto monnaie et en fait
la pièce raconte l'histoire de
l'inventeur aux États-Unis du Amazon
pardon de citer la marque mais comment
comment on échange des armes et de la
crypto monnaie sur le Dark web lui
l'avant il a inventé ça parce qu'il
fallait quand même l'inventer donc dans
ce spectacle c'est une vraie enquête
puisque le FBI la CIA ont couru après ce
monsieur très longtemps ils ont fini par
l'attraper c'est une histoire vraie et
j'ai pas envie de trop spoiler mais mais
vraiment vous allez apprendre plein de
choses et c'est totalement dingue c'est
une histoire de dingue en fait alors
justement de toute façon on peut
retrouver un toute la programmation sur
le site
tecs.fr merci beaucoup Florence d'avoir
été pardon avec nous sur sensation et
pour revoir ou réécouter cette émission
rendez-vous sur notre site et notre
application radio sensation
[Musique]